(pleasant music)
- Hi, members of the Yale
graduating Class of 2021.
I'm Robert Lopez, JE Class of 1997.
I'm a songwriter, best known
along with my wife, Kristen,
for co-writing the song "Let it Go"
and all the songs from
"Frozen," "Frozen 2,"
and most recently the theme
songs for "WandaVision."
And I am so excited
to get to be this year's
Yale Class Day speaker.
My time at Yale was one of
the highlights of my life.
There hasn't been a day
that I haven't thought
about some great person
I knew, great book I read
or great memory I have from Yale.
After I graduated, I moved
back home with my parents,
without whose fierce support
I could never have had
a career in the arts.
I joined a musical theater
songwriting workshop
where I met Jeff Marks with
whom I wrote the show "Avenue Q"
and Kristin Anderson, who
became my wife and my work wife,
my lyricist and my love.
And somewhere along the way, I
co-wrote "The Book of Mormon"
with Matt Stone and Trey Parker.
Over the span of my career,
I've been able to share in many awards
but always in collaboration
with some wonderful person.
So on Class Day, I plan to
talk about the saving grace
of collaboration and friendship
and how it can take
the weight of the world
off your stressed-out shoulders.
And I'll reflect a
little on my time at Yale
and share a memory and
probably even a song or two.
Of course, my speech will only be part
of the great tradition of Class Day.
I've spoken to the Class Day
committee and I'm so impressed
with them and everything they're planning.
It's gonna be great.
So I wanna say thanks to President Salovey
and everyone at Yale for
entrusting me with this.
It's a huge honor, and
I'm really looking forward
to seeing you on Class Day on May 23rd.
Thank you.